>>> NEW THIS MORNING RUSSIA SAYS
IT IS NOW WILLING TO DISCUSS A
PRISONER EXCHANGE WITH THE U.S.
THIS COMES LESS THAN 24 HOURS
AFTER A COURT NEAR MOSCOW
SENTENCED WNBA SUPERSTAR
BRITTNEY GRINER TO NINE YEARS
BEHIND BARS FOR HAVING CANNABIS
OIL, A SMALL AMOUNT, IN HER
LUGGAGE.
JOINING US NOW IS SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT GREENER IS
FACING RIGHT NOW, ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE, TREVOR REED.
HE RETURNED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN APRIL AFTER BEING IMPRISONED
IN RUSSIA FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS.
TREVOR, THANKS FOR BEING WITH US
THIS MORNING.
>> SURE.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> WERE YOU AT ALL SURPRISED BY
THIS SENTENCE WHEN YOU HEARD THE
AMOUNT OF TIME?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I WAS EXPECTING THEM TO GIVE
HER, YOU KNOW, THE MAXIMUM OR
CLOSE TO THE MAXIMUM, WHICH IS
WHAT THEY -- WHAT THEY DID.
>> DOES IT FEEL LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
SO FOR BRITTNEY'S CLASSIFICATION
OF CRIME, WHICH ACTUALLY I DON'T
THINK SHOULD EVEN BE UNDER THAT
CLASSIFICATION, BUT THEY HAVE,
YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE IT'S 0 TO 10
YEARS AND THEY GAVE HER 9, SO
PEOPLE IN RUSSIA WHO ARE
CONVICTED AND SENTENCED UNDER
THAT ARTICLE IN THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION USUALLY RECEIVE ABOUT
A YEAR, TWO YEARS MAYBE.
NINE IS UNHEARD OF.
I NEVER SAW THAT THE ENTIRE TIME
I WAS THERE, AND AS WELL AS IN
MY CASE.
I RECEIVED NINE AND THAT WAS
ACTUALLY THE LARGEST SENTENCE
EVER HANDED DOWN FOR THAT
CRIMINAL ARTICLE IN RUSSIA EVER.
SO, YEAH, I WASN'T SURPRISED BY
THAT AND, YOU KNOW, REGARDLESS
OF HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT BRITTNEY
GRINER'S CASE, THAT SENTENCE IS
CLEARLY POLITICAL.
THERE'S NO DENYING THAT.
>> LOGISTICALLY, TREVOR, WALK US
THROUGH WHAT HAPPENS NOW FOR
HER, BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH
THIS.
AS SHE IS TRANSPORTED, AS SHE
ARRIVES, WHEREVER SHE MAY BE.
>> YEAH, SO ONCE YOU'RE
CONVICTED IN RUSSIAN COURT YOU
DO HAVE A CHANCE TO GO TO
APPEALS AND APPEAL THAT DECISION
TO ANOTHER KANGAROO COURT IN
MOSCOW.
SO AFTER THAT TRIAL, YOU KNOW,
DEPENDING ON BRITTNEY'S DECISION
ON WHETHER SHE WANTS TO APPEAL
OR NOT, SHE MAY STAY IN MOSCOW
AT THE DETENTION FACILITY THAT
SHE'S ALREADY AT UNTIL HER
APPEALS ARE COMPLETED OR IF SHE
CHOOSES NOT TO GO TO APPEALS
THEY MAY TRANSFER HER TO A
FORCED LABOR CAMP.
AND CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS
CONSIDERING EXCHANGING HER, THEY
MAY ALSO DECIDE TO LEAVE HER IN
MOSCOW TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR HER
TO BE RETURNED TO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> BECAUSE IN YOUR CASE WHERE
YOU WERE WAS SEVERAL HOURS FROM
MOSCOW, RIGHT?
DESCRIBE FOR US WHAT THAT PRISON
WAS LIKE OR THAT FORCED LABOR
CAMP WAS LIKE.
>> YEAH, THERE IS -- IT'S
TERRIBLE SOMETIMES THAT IT COULD
BE JUST SOME FISH BONES OR BROTH
OF FISH BONES, YOU KNOW, POTATO
SOUP WITH -- IT'S MOSTLY WATER.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S FERAL CATS
THAT WANDER AROUND THERE ON THE
PRISON GROUNDS, ON THE PRISON
COMPOUND, DILAPIDATED BUILDINGS,
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT THERE
BASICALLY CONSISTS OF JUST A
CONCRETE ROOM WITH A HOLE IN THE
FLOOR FOR A TOILET.
JUST REALLY MIDDLE-AGED LOOKING
STUFF.
>> AND, LOOK, WE WERE TALKING
WHEN YOU WERE THERE WITH YOUR
PARENTS, THEY WERE SO WORRIED
ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHY WHEN YOU
DESCRIBE THE CONDITIONS.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT HER
HEALTH?
SAFETY?
>> YEAH, SURE, ANYONE WHO IS IN
A FORCED LABOR CAMP IN RUSSIA IS
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, FACING
SERIOUS THREATS TO THEIR HEALTH
BECAUSE OF MALNUTRITION, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S LITTLE TO NO
MEDICAL ATTENTION THERE
WHATSOEVER, TUBERCULOSIS RUNS
RAMPANT IN RUSSIAN PRISONS.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S DISEASES THAT
THEY HAVE THERE IN RUSSIA WHICH
ARE LARGELY EXTINCT IN THE
UNITED STATES NOW.
SO IT'S DEFINITELY A CONCERN FOR
HER HEALTH, PAUL WHELAN,
OBVIOUSLY, HAS BEEN IN A FORCED
LABOR CAMP FOR A VERY LONG TIME,
IT'S DEFINITELY A DANGEROUS
PLACE TO BE.
>> WHAT ARE YOUR WORRIES FOR
THEM, TREVOR, FOR BRITTNEY AND
FOR PAUL?
>> I MEAN, RIGHT NOW I'M TRYING
NOT TO -- TO FOCUS ON THAT, I'M
HOPING THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE
WILL BE AN EXCHANGE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THEM HOME, SO I'M
HOPING FOR THE BEST IN THAT.
>> I THINK WE ARE ALL HOPING FOR
THAT.
TREVOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS ALWAYS, FOR TALKING TO US.
I KNOW IT MUST BE TOUGH FOR
TALKING ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE,
BUT YOU'RE ALWAYS WILLING TO DO
IT AS YOU TRY TO RAISE AWARENESS
FOR BRITTNEY GRINER AND FOR PAUL
AND FOR OTHER DETAINED AMERICANS
AND WE APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.